(sirens blaring)
- [Mark] All right, Juicy Fruit.
Juicy Fruit, where'd you
grow up? Where are you from?
- [Juicy Fruit] Watts, California.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- [Juicy Fruit] No.
- [Mark] Who raised you?
- Well, I was in and out of
foster care and group homes.
- [Mark] Where was mom and dad?
- I really don't know.
I only seen my mother so often, so.
But my mother was an alcoholic,
my dad was too busy running the streets
gang banger and everything.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Pretty messed up.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff went on?
- Shit, I got raped for like 10 years.
- [Mark] In the foster system?
By who?
- By one of the guys that
actually worked in the house.
- [Mark] Did you say anything to anyone?
- I tried, nobody really
believed me about it.
But what could I do?
(sighs)
Well I just went around from
foster homes, group homes and
had somebody set my bed on fire
while I was in it, while I was asleep.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- While I was asleep at the, what was it?
The group because yeah, the group home.
(sighs deeply)
I hate talking about this.
- [Mark] If you'd rather not, it's okay.
I'll pay you either way.
- No, I'll finish.
What's the next question?
- [Mark] So you're molested for
10 years in the foster home,
was there any other abuse?
- Well, basically with
this guy that used to come,
they had a day shift,
a evening shift, and he had a night shift.
This one guy will come in
my room and come get me.
Basically, he'd chain me up like a dog.
(sighs)
- [Mark] This started what age?
- When I was like, what? 12, 13?
(sighs deeply)
- [Mark] I'm sorry, so you went
out on your own at what age?
- Well, off and on, I
was on my own basically
from the time I was
about, what? 10 till...
Shit, till time I turned 18.
I was off and on in between
group homes, on the street,
foster homes, in and out of jail.
- [Mark] And you started
working as a prostitute
at what age?
- 12.
- [Mark] 12.
Were you doing that on
your own or with a pimp?
- Yeah, I had a pimp.
Yeah, I had my daughter, what?
Right before I turned 18.
I was still out there making money.
I almost lost her to the
system because my mom...
Basically after making contact with her,
my mom tried to take my
daughter away from me
'cause she tried to say I was on,
basically on drugs and everything.
Like, I might smoke weed
but that's about it.
I went through court back and forth
with that for a long time.
And then I had my son
when I was, what? About turned 22.
Still working the streets.
I almost lost my son when I
was pregnant, turning date.
- [Mark] What happened?
Dude sucked me on my stomach so hard.
After he got finished handling business,
he took the money back,
basically, and he just left me there.
I was seven and a half months.
So they ended up having to
do an emergency C-section.
He came out four pounds, eight ounces.
Basically, he couldn't come home
the day that I left from the hospital.
He had to stay in there
for two extra months.
- [Mark] You still have your kids?
You do.
You're raising them?
Good for you.
(Juicy weeps and sniffles)
Tell me about your kids.
(sirens blaring)
- (sighs) Well, my daughter's
gonna be 17 next year.
She's 16 right now.
(sniffles and clear's throat)
My son is 14.
(sniffles)
- [Mark] They good kids?
- Very smart.
I just don't want my
daughter to be like me.
(sniffles)
- [Mark] You think there's a chance of her
doing the same thing?
- I hope not.
(weeps and sniffles)
(sniffles)
I don't want her to follow in
the same footsteps that I did.
(sighs deeply)
- [Mark] Does she know
what you do for work?
- [Juicy Fruit] I don't lie
to my kids about anything.
I let 'em know the truth about everything.
(Juicy whimpers)
(sniffles)
I love my kids to death.
I would do anything for them.
- [Mark] And you're still working today?
Do you make enough money
to support your family?
- [Juicy Fruit] Almost.
- [Mark] It's still a very
dangerous way to make a living.
You have kids to come home to and support.
- [Juicy Fruit] Yeah, 'cause
every time I go out there
I'm thinking, "Am I gonna make
it back to my kids or not?"
(sniffles)
- [Mark] Tell me about the
guys that are your customers.
- Oh, Lord. (chuckles)
You have to deal with these
guys, different attitudes.
Yeah, some of them might
be nice but very few.
You have some that'll pretend to be nice.
How you say, once you finish
handling whatever business
you have to handle with them, it's like,
they want to take the money back
or they want half of it back.
I'm like, "What?"
I've had to stab a guy in the leg before.
Because the dude basically
tried to hold me down afterwards and
thought he's gonna get his money back.
He thought he was gonna put hands on me.
I've been dragged by a car before
on my stomach, a whole block.
Just the beginning of this
year, I've been hit by a car
and I've been shot.
(sniffles)
But at the end of the day,
if I don't make money,
can't support me and my kids.
At the end of the day, I
still have to go out there
and do what I have to do.
So it's like, you can't
let stuff scare you
when you're out there.
Because should you let it scare you,
how can you make money?
And because I have my kids to support,
I have to do what I have to do.
- [Mark] Are you using drugs.
- I smoke weed.
- [Mark] How do you
think living this life,
working the streets has
changed you all these years?
- Um, think it's changed me a lot.
(sniffles)
Thank you.
- [Mark] How do you
think it's changed you?
- I think it's changed me a lot because
basically if everything
that had happened to me
wouldn't have happened to me,
I wouldn't be the person I am today also
'cause I've gained a lot of street smarts.
Not only do I have book smarts,
I have street smarts too.
So made me a lot smarter,
basically being in the streets.
Because like, a lot of times
I know what to look for
before I get in the car.
- [Mark] You use your intuition?
- Exactly, my first mind so.
- [Mark] What kind of
stuff do you shy away from?
- Too fidgety, too anxious
for me to get in the car,
too like, flashy of money too much.
That's bell ringers right there.
'Cause that's like, nine times out of 10,
they gonna wanna pull into an alley
or something like that or
in front of somewhere dark
where they can't nobody
see in the car or anything.
And 9 times out of 10, they gon' rape you
or try to kill you.
I've been kidnapped by pimps.
I've been kidnapped by a pimp before,
to where my kids thought I was dead.
They had me in a cage.
They fed me like a animal.
They had a shark collar around my neck.
- [Mark] How do you think girls get so
brainwashed to work with a pimp?
- Because they believe
that these dudes love them
but in all honestly, these dudes,
they don't really love them.
They love the money that they get them.
How you say?...
These guys out here, they
learn how to finesse a female.
Tell a female what she wants to hear.
And whatever that he
thinks she wants to hear,
that's what he's gonna tell her.
Whatever sounds good.
They'll play with your
emotions and your feelings
so they can get what they want.
And then when their use of you is over,
Hey, they go to the next one.
And they'll still try to string you along.
- [Mark] What advice would
you give to a young girl
who's considering doing this kind of work?
- Don't do it, stay in school.
You know, get good
grades, don't ditch class.
Just listen to your parents
and don't do drugs at all, period.
Not even weed.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned
in your years of doing this?
- Be careful who you trust.
You have to be very careful.
(sniffles)
- [Mark] You think this kind of work
has changed the way you view men?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] In what way?
- To where I don't even...
I'm bisexual. I used to be gay.
I used to just do this out
here like, for the money.
But it's like dudes, it's like,
I don't even like either now.
And I'm just like, just
everybody leave me alone.
It's like, this shit that
made me hate people so bad.
It's like, damn.
The only reason I'm still living
and going through life
is because of my kids.
They give me a reason to
wake up in the morning.
(weeping)
(sniffles)
My kid's name is Lynnita Smith
and my son name is Jesse.
Jesse Lynn.
(sniffles and sighs)
- [Mark] You're proud of your kids?
- Hmm?
- I'm very proud.
- [Mark] You should be proud
of yourself too though.
(sniffles)
- I do the best I can.
- [Mark] You're trying to protect them
from the same thing you went through.
You never had parents.
(Juicy weeps and sniffles)
- [Mark] Have you ever been in love?
(sniffles)
- (chuckles) Hell no.
Not what I thought was love... (chuckles)
What I thought was love.
- [Mark] Do you think love exists?
- Huh?
True love.
- I really don't.
Because anybody can say I love you.
What really matters is,
I'll tell you like this;
hit rock bottom.
When you hit rock bottom,
then you'll see who really loves you.
You never know who really loves you
or who's really there for you
until you really need somebody.
(sniffles)
- [Mark] All right, Juicy Fruit.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- [Juicy Fruit] Thank you.
(sniffles)
- [Mark] I'm gonna take care of you.
You'll make some nice money this weekend.